[Music]
you all know the truth of what i'm going
to say i think the intuition that
inequality is divisive and socially
corrosive has been around since before
the french revolution
what's changed is we now can look at the
evidence
we can compare societies more and less
equal societies and see what inequality
does
i'm going to take you through that data
and then explain why the links that i
think
i'm going to be showing you exist
but first see what a miserable lot we
are
i want to start though with a paradox
this shows you life expectancy against
gross national income how rich countries
are on average and you see the countries
on the right like norway and the usa are
twice as rich as israel greece portugal
on the left
and it makes no difference to their life
expectancy at all there's no suggestion
of a relationship there
but if we look within our societies
there are extraordinary social gradients
in health running right across society
this again is life expectancy these are
small areas of england and wales the
poorest on the right the richest on the
left
not a difference between the poor and
the rest of us even the people just
below the top
have less good health than the people at
the top
so income means something very important
within our societies
and nothing between them
the explanation of that paradox
is that within our societies we're
looking at relative income
or social position social status
where we are in relation to each other
and the size of the gaps between us
and as soon as you've got that idea
you should immediately wonder what
happens if we widen the differences
or compress them make the income
differences bigger or smaller
and that's what i'm going to show you
i'm not using any hypothetical data i'm
taking data from the un it's the same as
the world bank has on the scale of
income differences in these rich
developed market democracies
the measure we've used just because it's
easy to understand and you can download
it is how much richer the top twenty
percent than the bottom twenty percent
in each country
and you see in the more equal countries
on the left
japan finland norway sweden the top
twenty percent about three and a half
four times as rich as the bottom twenty
percent
but at the mo unequal end uk portugal
usa singapore the differences are twice
as big
on that measure we are twice as unequal
as some of the other successful market
democracies
now i'm going to show you what that does
to our societies
we collected data on problems with
social gradients the kind of problems
that are more common at the bottom of
the social ladder
internationally comparable data on life
expectancy on kids maths and literacy
scores on infant mortality rates
homicide rates
proportion of the population in prison
teenage birth rates levels of trust
obesity
mental illness which in
standard diagnostic
classification includes drug and alcohol
addiction and social mobility
we put them here all in one index
they're all weighted equally where
country is is sort of average score on
these things
and there you see it in relation to the
measure of inequality i've just shown
you
which i shall use over and over again in
the data
the more unequal countries doing worse
on all these kinds of social problems
it's an extraordinary close correlation
but if you look at that same index of
health and social problems
in relation to gnp per capita gross
national income there's nothing there
no correlation anymore
we were a little bit worried that people
might think we'd been choosing problems
to suit our argument and just
manufactured this this evidence so we
also looked in we did a paper in the
british medical journal on the unicef
index of child well-being it has 40
different components put together by
other people
it contains whether
kids can talk to their parents whether
they have books at home what
immunization rates are like where
there's bullying at school everything
goes into it
here it is in relation to that same
measure of inequality
kids doing worse in the more unequal
societies highly significant
relationship
but once again
if you look at that measure of child
well-being
in relation to national income per
person
there's no relationship no suggestion of
a relationship
what all the data i've shown you so far
says is the same thing
the average well-being of our societies
is not dependent any longer
on national income and economic growth
that's very important in poorer
countries but not in the rich developed
world
but the differences between us and where
we are in relation to each other now
matter very much
i'm going to show you some of the
separate bits of our index here for
instance is trust it's simply the
proportion of the population who agree
most people can be trusted comes from
the world values survey
who see it the more on equal end
it's about 15 percent of the population
who feel they can trust others
but in the more equal societies it rises
to 60 or 65 percent
and if you look at measures of
involvement in community life or social
capital
very similar relationships closely
related to inequality
i may say we did all this work twice we
did it first on these rich developed
countries
and then as a separate test bed we
repeated it all on the 50 american
states asking just the same question do
the more unequal states do worse on all
these kinds of measures
so here is trust from the general social
survey of the federal government related
to inequality
very similar scatter over similar range
of levels of trust
same thing is going on
basically we found that uh almost
anything that's related to trust
internationally is related to trust
amongst the 50 states in that separate
test bed
we're not just talking about
a fluke
this is mental illness who put together
figures using the same diagnostic
interviews on random samples of the
population to allow us to compare rates
of mental illness in each society
this is the percent of the population
with any mental illness in the preceding
year
and it goes from about eight percent
up to three times that
whole societies with three times the
level of mental illness of others
and again closely related to inequality
this is violence
these red dots are american states and
the blue
triangles are canadian provinces but
look at the scale of the differences
it goes from 15 homicides per million up
to 150.
this is the proportion of the population
in prison
there's about a tenfold difference there
log scale up the side but it goes from
about 40 to 400 people in prison
that relationship is not mainly driven
by more crime
in some places that's part of it
but most of it is about more punitive
sentencing harsher sentencing
and the more unequal societies are more
likely also to retain the death penalty
here we have
children dropping out of high school
again quite big differences
extraordinarily damaging if you're
talking about using the talents of the
population
this is social mobility
it's actually a measure of mobility
based on income basically it's asking do
rich fathers have rich sons and poor
fathers have poor sons or is there no
relationship between the two
and at the more unequal end
father's income is much more important
in the uk usa and in countries the
scandinavian countries father's income
is much less important there's more
social mobility
and as we like to say i know a lot of
americans in the audience here
if americans want to live the american
dream they should go to denmark
i've shown you just a few things in
italics here i could have shown you a
number of other problems are all
problems that tend to be more common at
the bottom of the social gradient
but there are
endless
problems with social gradients that are
worse in more unequal countries not just
a little bit worse but anything from
twice as common to 10 times as common
think of the expense the human cost of
that
i want to go back though to this graph
that i showed you earlier where we put
it all together to make two points
one is that in graph after graph we find
the countries that do worst whatever the
outcome
seem to be the more unequal ones
and the ones that do well seem to be the
nordic countries in japan
so what we're looking at is general
social dysfunction related to inequality
it's not just one or two things that go
wrong it's most things
the other really important point i i
want to make on this graph is that if
you look at the bottom sweden and japan
there are very
different countries in all sorts of ways
the position of women how closely they
keep to the nuclear family there are
opposite ends of the polls in terms of
the rich developed world
but another really important difference
is how they get their greater equality
sweden has huge differences in earnings
and it narrows the gap through taxation
generous welfare states generous
benefits and so on
japan is rather different though it
starts off with much smaller differences
in earnings before tax it has lower
taxes it has a smaller welfare state
and in our analysis of the american
states we find rather the same contrast
there's some states that do well through
redistribution some states do well
because they have smaller income
differences before tax
so we conclude that it doesn't much
matter how you get your greater equality
as long as you get there somehow
i'm not talking about perfect equality
i'm talking about what exists in rich
developed market democracies
another really surprising
part of this picture
is that it's not just the poor who
affected by inequality
there seems to be some truth in john
dunn's no man is an island
in a number of uh studies it's possible
to compare how people do
in more and less equal countries at each
level in the social hierarchy
this just one example
it's infant mortality some swedes very
kindly classified a lot of their infant
deaths according to the british
registrar general's socio-economic
classification
and so
it's anachronically a classification by
father's occupation so single parents go
on their own but then the low where it
says low social class that's uh
unskilled manual occupations it goes
through towards the skilled manual
occupations in the middle gen then the
junior non-manual going up the high to
the professional occupations doctors
lawyers directors of larger companies
you see there that sweden does better
than britain all the way across the
social hierarchy
the biggest differences at the bottom of
society but even at the top there seems
to be a small benefit to being in a more
equal society
we show that on about five different
sets of data covering educational
outcomes and health in the united states
and internationally
and that seems to be the general picture
that greater equality makes most
difference at the bottom but has some
benefit even at the top
but i should say a few words about
what's going on
i think i'm looking and talking about
the psychosocial effects of inequality
more to do with feelings of superiority
and inferiority of being valued and
devalued respected and disrespected
and of course those feelings of
the status competition that comes out of
that drives the consumerism in our
society
uh it also leads to status insecurity
we worry more about how we're judged and
seen by others whether we're regarded as
attractive clever
all that kind of thing
uh the social evaluative judgments uh
increase uh the fear of the those social
evaluative judgments
interestingly some work parallel work
going on in social psychology
some people reviewed 208 different
studies in which volunteers had been
invited into psychological laboratory
and had their stress hormones their
responses to doing
stressful tasks measured
and in the review what they were
interested in seeing is what kind of
stressors most reliably raise
levels of cortisol essential stress
hormone
and the conclusion was it was tasks that
included social evaluative threat
threats to self-esteem or social status
in which others can negatively judge
your performance
those kind of stressors have a very
particular effect on
the physiology of stress
now we have been criticized of course
there are people who dislike this stuff
and people who find it very surprising
i should tell you though that when
people criticize us for picking and
choosing data we never pick and choose
data we have an absolute rule that if
our data source has data for one of the
countries we're looking at it goes into
the analysis
our data source decides whether it's a
reliable data we don't
otherwise that would introduce bias
what about other countries
there are 200 studies
of health in relation to income
inequality
in the academic peer-reviewed journals
this isn't confined to these countries
here hiding a very simple demonstration
of the same
countries the same measure of inequality
one problem after another
why don't we control for other factors
well we've shown you that gnp per capita
doesn't make any difference and of
course others using more sophisticated
methods in the literature have
controlled for poverty and education and
so on
um
what about causality
uh correlation in itself doesn't prove
causality we spend a good bit of time
and indeed people know the causal links
quite well in some of these outcomes the
big change in our understanding of
drivers of chronic of health in the rich
developed world is how important chronic
stress from social sources is
affecting the immune system the
cardiovascular system
or for instance the reason why violence
becomes more common in more unequal
societies is because people
are
sensitive to being looked down on
i should say that uh to deal with this
we've got to deal with the post-tax
things and the pre-tax things we've got
to constrain income the bonus culture
incomes at the top i think we must make
uh bosses accountable to their employees
in any way we can
i think the take-home message though
is that we can improve the real quality
of human life
by reducing the differences in incomes
between us suddenly we have a handle on
the psychosocial well-being of whole
societies and that's exciting thank you
[Applause]
you